- [Voiceover] One of the characters
in Milton Murayama's
novel is considered blank
because he deliberately defies
an oppressive hierarchical society.
So we can think about what word (mumbles)
you'd be considered blank, if
you're deliberately defying
an oppressive hierarchical society.
So let's think about it, so
the first choice is rebellious.
Well this seems pretty good, rebellious...
if you're rebellious,
that means that you're
rebelling against something,
that you tend to rebel.
To rebel means that
you're fighting the power,
you are rising up against the man.
You are deliberately defying an oppressive
hierarchical society, so this
seems to be a pretty good fit.
One of the characters in
Milton Murayama's novel
is considered rebellious,
because he rebels against
an oppressive hierarchical society.
He deliberately defies an
oppressive hierarchical society.
You could literally replace
the word, he deliberately...
You could replace the word
defies with the word rebel,
and it would make complete sense,
because he deliberately rebels...
rebels against...
rebels against an oppressive
hierarchical society.
So, someone who defies, or rebels against,
well, they're rebellious, but we can look
at these other choices to just make sure
that they don't also fit in some way.
So here they're saying...
so choice B would be,
one of the characters in
Milton Murayama's novel
is considered impulsive.
Well impulsive just means that
you don't think before you
act, you just do something.
You could be impulsive in
a lot of different ways,
it could be, in some ways,
rebelling, but it could
be impulsive, just not acting
before you're thinking.
So this doesn't seem as close to
deliberately defying an
oppressive hierarchical society.
Artistic, well that doesn't
really, that's not even,
deliberately defying an
oppressive hierarchical society.
Sometimes artists have done
things like that, but rebelling,
or being rebellious is much closer to this
than just being artistic,
you could be artistic
and have nothing to do with defying
an oppressive hierarchical society.
You'd just wanna go into a
field and work on your art.
Industrious, well
industrious means you're...
you're always busy doing
things, you're productive,
you're working hard, and
someone who's rebellious
might be industrious in their rebellion,
but it doesn't mean that
you're deliberately defying
an oppressive hierarchical society.
So, if anything, you
could be very industrious
being a part of the oppressive
hierarchical society,
you're busy oppressing people. (laughs)
So we'll rule that out, and then,
it's considered tyrannical, because
he deliberately defies an
oppressive hierarchical society.
So tyrannical, you see the...
root of tyrant right over
there, so that's really...
you're being like a tyrant.
And so, someone who's rebelling
against, or who's defying
an oppressive hierarchical society,
that's kind of the opposite of a tyrant.
A tyrant is someone who would run
the oppressive hierarchical society.
So I would rule that one out, as well,
so we can feel even better.
But if I was doing this
under time-pressure,
I got to rebellious, that feels right,
you're rebelling against
the hierarchical society.
I would just go with that and move on,
and if you have some extra
time, you could come back
and review these other choices.